MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome to 8.701.
So in this lecture, we'll give
you the first introduction
to Feynman diagram.
This is part 1 out of a few
sections on Feynman diagrams.
So this is really meant to
introduce the topic such
that we can use the
same language to talk
about Feynman diagrams
before we then later on are
able to use them as
a tool to calculate
interesting processes.
This brings me right
to the essence already.
What is a Feynman diagrams
and what can it be used for?
They arise from
pertubative calculations
of amplitude for reactions.
And that's exactly how we're
going to use them later on.
It turns out that the
mathematical terms
in the perturbation series can
be represented as a diagram.
And then you can
turn this around
and use the diagram in order
to perform a calculation.
So each of the diagrams then
indicates a particular factor
in the calculation.
Again, and then you
have a rule which
allows you to,
after drawing, you
can then put the pieces
together in order
to perform [INAUDIBLE]
calculation.
The derivation of
those tools or rules
is beyond the content
of this course.
But I will teach you how
to actually use diagrams
in order to calculate things.
So here's one
example of a diagram.
Let me just put this down
here so you can see this.
So this is an electron
radiating a photon.
You see components
like those lines here.
Those represent particles
with energy and momentum
also what to consider the spin.
And they meet at a point.
This point here is
called a vertex.
And this is where the
interaction takes place.
And in this example.
The vertex is labeled
with a q or e,
representing the charge, the
electric charge, which gives us
the strength of the coupling.
We already discussed when
we talked about units
that we can express the strength
of the electromagnetic--
the coupling in QED with
the electric charge.
And that's shown below again.
The amplitude then turns out to
be proportional to the charge
or to this coupling.
And the diagrams with n vertices
for n of those components
here get a factor e,
the charge, to the nth
power in the amplitude,
and e to the second.
Because if we're going to
calculate a probability,
you have to square
the amplitude.
You get a factor of e to 2n.
Again, don't get
confused-- e is charge.
So for n vertices, there will
be a factor alpha to the nth
power for the probability.
And so since alpha
is 1/137, you see
that if I want to
do a calculation,
and diagrams which have n
vertices will be suppressed,
will not contribute
much to our perturbation
serious because alpha is
much, much smaller than 1.
So this is already an
interesting finding.
Can restrict yourself to
calculating diagrams which
have a couple of
vertices or n vertices,
but you don't have to
calculate the entire series.
You want to measure
your calculation
with experimental findings.
Interesting here--
antiparticles.
If you have a specific
vertex and you calculated it,
it can be reused.
It can be reused for
example by replacing
a particle with an
antiparticle or by re-labeling.
One thing I haven't
explained to you yet,
you have to define
when you write them
which is the direction of time.
We'll come to this direction.
And so in this
case here, you have
a particle and an antiparticle
unrelating to a photon.
So far, so good so.
This is again a good
point to stop and just
try to read the diagrams.
Note that what happens in this
discussion when you actually
change the direction of time--
forward down.
You want either directions.
So now if you want to
calculate the reaction,
it's not sufficient to
just use one word vertex.
Why?
Because a single vertex will not
be able to give us a reaction.
You can simply see
this when you look
at something like an electron
plus electron photon.
This is not really possible
because of energy and momentum
conservation in this diagram.
So you need a couple of vertices
in order to make a reaction.
So this here is, again,
we have potentially
the time going this direction.
There's a scattering between
an electron and a muon
through the exchange
of a photon.
Both particles have
electric charge of e.
And then you can
just calculate what
is the probability for a
process like this to occur.
We'll see how to do this
technically later on.
But hopefully you have
a first impression.
Again, let's label
this now very quickly.
So you have an
incoming particle,
a second incoming particle,
outgoing particles,
and an exchange particle.
So this exchange
particle is a photon.
And there's two vertices
in this diagram.